All right, Michael.
So I'm going to deal with your request
by trying to go through an exercise
with you, where we try to figure out
what these options are, and there's
going to be a secret point here that
has to do as always with abstraction.
So here's what to do.
So we've got the same little grid
world that we had before up here but
I've introduced another grid world.
Do you recognize this grid world?
>> It looks like a very tiny,
little game of Pac Man.
>> It is exactly a tiny,
So what I want to do with this tiny,
little game of Pac Man,
which again is just a grid world, is I
want to explore this notion of options
and see what we can
figure out about them.
So everybody remembers Pac Man.
So Michael, for the benefit of the
audience that has never played Pac Man,
all zero of them, why don't you
explain to us how Pac Man works.
>> Sure, so in the game where
a little Jewish guy named Pac Man and
we're running around in the grid, we're
the yellow guy and we chomp, chomp,
chomp, chomp, chomp.
We can't go through the blue walls.
We're being pursued by [LAUGH]
it looks like a sort of-
>> Careful.
>> Yeah.
[LAUGH] I'm going to go with
the french fry goblins from McDonald's.
So as we move around in the grid,
we consume those little dots,
little pellet's, and
that gives us points.
If we can actually clear all the little
dots and the big dots from the screen,
then we have successfully
completed the screen and
we get an even more
exciting challenge next.
>> Yes.
>> But I want to say that there's one
other important thing is that if we
eat one of those power pellet's,
the big fat dots,
then the tables are turned
on our ghost friends.
And we can actually,
if we touch them, consume them.
We get points.
And then they have to, I believe their
eyeballs run away and regenerate.
>> Yes, that's exactly what happens,
just like in real life.
So, yeah.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So the ghosts touch us, we die,
unless we've had the power pellet's, and
then they allow us to eat the ghost but
only for limited amount of time,
that doesn't last forever.
Once I get a big fat pellet, I don't
get to do it for the rest of the game
it last for some amount of time which-
>> For limited time only.
>> Limited time only.
And I don't remember if that time
is fixed or that time is random,
I think it's fixed but maybe not.
And there are different versions of Pac
Man that have slightly different rules,
but those are the basic rules.
So, here's the exercise
I want to go through.
Now obviously, and when I say obvious,
I'm saying that to beat down anyone
who doesn't think it's obvious,
there are four atomic actions, left,
right, up and down,
north, south, east and
west just like in any other grid world,
and that's pretty much what we're given.
So here's the exercise I
want you to go through.
It's got sort of two parts to it and
this is actually an exercise that we
have done with other people as
a part of studies we've done.
I want you to think about options
that you might create here.
If you were going to
describe to a human being,
here are the things you
need to accomplish,
here are the things you need to do
in this game in order to play it and
play it well presumably, what kind
of action would you come up with?
So, I'm asking you do the same thing
that I asked you to do before.
Where you said, well go to the doorway,
and you know that kind of thing.
So, I'm asking you do the same
thing here but in Pac Man land.
>> Sure, I can give that a try.
I mean, I feel like in some ways this is
is harder than the other example because
it was nice to be able to just
navigate to that plus one and
know that our task was complete.
Here, there's a lot of things going on.
>> Yeah, but you have to simplify it for
me and so abstract away.
Simplify it for me.